[Music]
is the sunshine state throwing shade as
woke new yorkers try to invade yeah if
you're a lefty hipster searching for sun
don't go to florida and ruin their fun
that's the message of fired up floridian
left for new york residents on their
cars last weekend they have cars there
cops in palm beach say vehicles with new
york license plates received letters on
their windows with a short but scathing
message quote if you are one of those
woke people leave florida you will be
happier elsewhere as will we
end quote love saying end quote
which is still friendlier than the
messages on cars in san francisco which
is eat me written with a pile of human
poop
takes a while to do that
several people reported the letters to
palm beach police
did i say people i'm sorry i meant
but after an investigation it was
determined a crime hadn't been committed
said a spokesman quote residents were
concerned about the lack of civility and
respect for personal property we
understood that concern as uncivil as it
may be and not characteristic of our
community it is not a crime
now of course florida has seen a
population boom a lot coming from new
york one former new yorker who now lives
in palm beach said the letters were
another sign that our democracy is in
peril there it is again well that seems
like an overreaction or exactly what
you'd expect from a big crybaby wuss
from this city
if there was ever a sign our democracy
is in peril i'd put my money on the new
pro-criminal directives coming from new
york city's woke d.a
and it's that crap that's causing new
yorkers to flee for florida in the first
place so instead of calling the cops
maybe take the flyers with polite
silence it sure beats a brick to the
head in times square you jackasses
i'm in a bad mood
what happened whittaker i was in a good
you know what it's because i've had i've
been sick for 12 days i'm pissed off i
can't control it
i need you to be proud usually the crowd
is here to laugh at your jokes and rob's
sitting here stone-faced with me like
what did we get ourselves into
i'm leaning pretty far in this direction
but in all seriousness i mean the these
people are right and these were not
threatening these were just don't bring
the things that broke new york city down
here and break it here because things
are really nice in florida i was just
down there over new year's yeah very
nice disneyland was beautiful disney
world disney i'm sorry you're right i'm
from iowa
he had so much fun he forgot what it was
called
what's your favorite ride uh i like the
the what is not the yeti but uh the
adventure avalanche yeah it's himalayas
were you hammered
you know what but as long as you didn't
say the tower of terror which is the
most the worst take take some mushrooms
it's a small world
take them just you could have stopped it
take the mushrooms well yeah that's a
good ride anyway
the frozen ride wasn't too bad either
the frozen
speed yeah i loved the simpsons ride um
and then the spongebob anyone where
you're just sitting in a chair cat and
that everything else is moving around
you i like that i don't like people who
put flyers on my car either but who
calls the cops right i people who would
call the cops losers don't want to hang
out with them but also i agree with you
the person who actually typed this up
printed out you know like if i went over
to hang out with somebody and they were
like what we're gonna do is
print a bunch of stuff and put on
people's cars and see if they're woke
then i'd be like can we just drink yeah
yeah can we just drink yeah i just uh
everyone in this but yeah calling the
cops over a piece of paper unless it's
like detailed descriptions of how to
kill me i'm not going to do it they've
got to be detailed yes i apologize for
that and i didn't put it on cars i just
put in everybody's mailbox
downtown you know degan you can contrast
this with new york where i think you
could probably carjack somebody with a
gun and still get released as long as
you don't shoot somebody but the sheriff
in florida wanted to like charge
somebody over a flyer
yeah that's just to keep the women quiet
like you know just nod your head and
eventually she'll go away yeah cat would
xerox her bare butt though
people's windshields again yes
with me holding up the top of the xerox
machine they're always there for me um i
have a different type of that mean i
have to start disinfecting the cockpit
yeah
we're disease spreaders by the way
um
but i have a different take on this
because the people somebody printing out
these flyers is the person who doesn't
know how to work the twitters yeah
because that's where the lonely bitter
people usually go to air their
grievances
and use this as a public service
announcement a lot of new yorkers are
moving to florida don't touch their
hearts yeah
because you know what if it's me and you
put your mitts on my automobile i'm
showing up at your house and i will key
your car and i'll take a knife to every
single one of your tires including
despair and i'll do it every day
seven days a week for at least a year
that's a fun little prank just just
knifing that spare is it true i think
that if you knife all but one of the
tires and the insurance can't cover it
but
we're gonna find out after this
what a better time to bring it up than
when i'm on tv exactly
exactly and when somebody flashes their
brides with you
you're going to be part of a gang land
murder rob yes um i think what they're
saying is that you know they don't want
people bringing their votes down with
them i i love new yorkers and they're
great you know because i've been to
florida this uh last month uh new york
now obviously yeah and with the new laws
though up here they're saying this isn't
illegal this isn't illegal i wore this
watch i'm walking through manhattan i'm
like if i have to kill someone i get a
free knife
what are they doing with this but one of
my favorite things in uh in new york
though there's a flight out of i want to
say westchester into west palm and we
call it here's how cool new yorkers are
they call it the miracle flight because
when you get on there's 15 wheelchairs
when you land in florida no one needs a
chair we're out of here [ __ ]
i'm serious hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else